Firebase Storage is now officially supported by Angular Fire 2, which means uploading files
from an Angular application is easier than ever before.
In this episode I'm going to take you through the new features in the Angular Fire 2 storage
module, then we'll use it to build a drop zone file uploader from scratch.
In addition to uploading files to Firebase Storage, it can also control the entire upload
process by pausing, canceling, or resuming an upload.
There's a whole bunch of other cool stuff I want to show you, but first make sure to
like and subscribe and grab the source code from AngularFirebase.com.
Before we jump into the code, I want to give you a few more details about how the Angular
Fire 2 storage module works.
When we drag and drop a file, it's going to start an Angular Fire upload task, which will
immediately start uploading the file to your Firebase storage bucket.
You can then monitor the upload progress as an observable.
The snapshot is emitted several times per second, so you can do things like update your
progress bar or just provide the user with some helpful feedback.
When the process is complete, it will give you back the download URL that you can show
in your front end UI.
Now let's go ahead and build this thing.
We'll start with a brand new Angular Fire app, and then inside that project, install Angular
Fire 2 and Firebase.
Then inside of your Angular environment, add your Firebase project config.
And lastly, we'll go into the app module and initialize our Angular Fire app.
I'm bringing in both the Angular Fire Storage module and the Firestore database for some
advanced stuff I'll show you.